let's discuss the absolute best remedy
for candida I'm also going to talk about
how to prevent candida but I first want
to help you understand what candida
really is
and there's some information that a lot
of people just don't realize in your gut
you know we always talk about the
microbiome right all the friendly
bacteria well a good portion of the
microbes in your gut are fungi and
candida is one type of fungus
and collectively all the different types
of funguses are called the microbiome
m-y-c-o and that is the family of
friendly fungi and just so you know the
great majority of these fungi are not
unfriendly they work together with the
bacteria to help you in many different
ways for the immune system for digestion
for other nutrients to be absorbed
it's not until we alter this bacteria
the microbiome that we get a problem
with the fungus okay because it changes
the environment and I'm specifically
talking about an antibiotic one of the
biggest side effects from taking
antibiotics is an overgrowth of candida
or other types of yeast or even mold now
this is interesting because in the soil
you also have fungi and bacteria and
having this Optimum ratio really
supports plant growth if you have a
ratio that is not correct you're going
to have a difficult time growing
vegetables it may be good for weeds but
not other plants so in our bodies
bacteria releases
certain chemicals and things that keep
this fungus friendly and prevent it from
turning unfriendly and becoming
pathogenic and so if the environment
changes
this fungus starts to change its
relationship with us no longer is it
helping us now it's going to hurt us and
so there's five main category of things
that this bacteria release
to help keep the fungus and the candida
in check they make small chain fatty
acids okay one of them is called
butyrate and these fatty acids come as a
byproduct of you consuming like
vegetable fiber okay from the fiber it
changes into these fatty acids and then
the colon uses them for energy they're
good for regulating your blood sugars
but they're also really good as an
anti-fungal and then also these bacteria
make medium chain triglycerides you've
probably heard of like MCT oil and that
actually can help someone generate
ketones right well medium chain
triglycerides also are a byproduct of
your own bacteria in fact they can even
act as an antibacterial they kind of
keep everything being friendly okay and
they prevent an overgrowth of the
pathogens MCT oil that's pretty
interesting and one unique thing about
this candida or an overgrowth of any
fungus is that it prefers
and more alkaline environment okay
because one of the byproducts of this
fungus or this candida is it releases
ammonia okay ammonia is extremely
alkaline on the pH scale it's like 11
which is super super alkaline and
normally the gut pH should be about 5
5.5 and so understanding the pH is very
very important into having this balance
of the good guys and the bad guys but as
soon as you get a Candida infection or
like a yeast infection or you get this
like the white tongue or it can grow in
your private parts and this type of
thing you'll notice that the person's
breath
smells a bit like ammonia that is coming
from the candida and that also tells us
what the pH is of their large intestine
which should be slightly acidic and now
it's too alkaline and so it's kind of a
breeding ground for more candida now
another thing that the bacteria produce
to keep this fungus in check is bile
salts so bile salts are another
inhibitory factor for this fungus but
not tatka which is a another bile salt
that I've mentioned that's not the one
that you need you want to take a regular
bile salt and you want to take that an
empty stomach and the bacteria make
other things that keep this fungus in
check like antimicrobial peptides and
there's several others when we take an
antibiotic we wipe out the bacteria and
now the fungus has free reign to start
to do whatever they want and they take
advantage of the situation and they
overgrowth and the normal candida then
starts developing filaments and
mold-like projections and become the
pathogenic version of this candida
simply because we no longer have the
controlling of buffering factors from
the bacteria and so we talk about
dysbiosis which is an alteration in the
diversity and the type of microbes for
bacteria you also have this biopsis of
the fungus as well so you can have a big
problem and now they develop as a side
effect unfriendly bacteria not to
mention resistance to the fungicide but
other problems too and so it's really a
circular thing one thing creates another
problem and creates another problem and
you're trying to treat it around and
round and that's why I want to give you
the big picture so you can understand it
and not get stuck in the treating of
symptoms and when someone takes an
antibiotic make sure you at the same
time take a probiotic and that way you
can kind of um at least minimize the
damage because it's going to take like
about at least 40 Days for you to
re-establish these microbes and
sometimes people are on antibiotics a
lot longer get to a point where it's
it's going to be really hard to
reestablish the normal flora that you
once had and when you have this
unfriendly candida you greatly increase
inflammation in your gut okay so we have
this the pH changes you get
inflammation of the gut you get
ulcerative colitis irritable bowel
syndrome it increases your risk for a
lot of additional problems in your gut
not to mention the bloating the craving
for sugar which I'm going to get to the
itchiness and the private parts the
white tongue the fatigue all sorts of
things also I found an interesting
research paper on colorectal cancer
there's a high incidence of having
dysbiosis with the microbiome the family
of funguses that could probably set you
up for risk of getting colon cancer I
mean if you think about it it makes
sense because both the friendly fungus
and the friendly bacteria help you with
your immune system and I'm talking in a
major way some reports state that up to
80 percent of your immune system is
these other entities that are growing in
our digestive system now let's talk
about how to get rid of candida okay of
course the best way is to prevent it and
you can use what I'm going to tell you
to prevent but if you have candida
here's some things that will be very
effective okay
the first thing is to take a probiotic
okay a good probiotic to put back in the
Flora to then keep this candida in check
that's the most important thing and you
need to start on something immediately
but one of the things that feeds Candida
is sugar and milk sugar is definitely a
sugar so let's talk about Dairy right
can you do like yogurt or kefir well it
does have some lactose unless you can
find some kefir without lactose I would
stay away from dairy at this point okay
instead you want to do probably some
good probiotic but also Probiotic foods
as in sauerkraut kimchi pickles
fermented vegetables those types of
things and and also those things are
very acidic and it's going to change the
pH making the environment very
unfriendly for this pathogenic candida
the other point about sugar is that
candida cannot exist without glucose and
other sugars what does that mean it
means that if you starve this candida
off
by going on keto low carb no sugars
it's going to go away glucose is the
worst sugar but a lot of carbs turn into
glucose so we just want to avoid
carbohydrates unless they're vegetable
carbohydrates there's also other types
of sugars like in sugar alcohols if
you're on keto you know about sugar
alcohols like Xylitol there's also
sorbitol which I don't recommend that or
Mannitol well apparently those can also
feed candida not to the same extent as
glucose but by a hundred percent which
is like one tenth of a thousand but
still so I would avoid sugar alcohols if
you're trying to get rid of candida now
the fact that you're reducing your
sugars okay down to zero and your carbs
way down
this means that your body is going to go
into a state of ketosis and certain
ketones are in the family of butyric
acid so that can help suppress this
fungal infection in fact ketones are
acidic so now we're going to change the
pH back to where we need it and that can
help as well that's why the ketogenic
diet is so important and capric acid in
coconut oil
and in MCT oil can be very beneficial as
an anti-fungal so that's something else
you could include in the diet as far as
other things that can help you vegetable
fiber so you can have like salads and
vegetables it's going to be totally fine
have your protein but don't get into the
sugar alcohols or the other carbs or
even fruit and also you can add like
natural herbal antibiotics okay that's
the icing in the cake you can add like
garlic oregano oil thyme Sage the
turmeric for example is another one all
right so now I think you have enough
information to turn things around really
fast but since we're on the topic of
antibiotics and natural antibiotics if
you haven't seen this video check it out
I put it up right here